for newly qualified firefighter Jade
Bove going on strike as a last resort
but when wages for some are less than 12
pounds an hour it's also essential
people are struggling and people having
to go and work after they've finished
this work we're constantly putting our
life at risk for the job that we do like
we've just had the last one of our own
again
um so every time we're going to work
there could be a chance that we're not
going back home to our families and with
the job we do as well it's a high risk
of getting cancer
um I just don't feel like we're paid
enough at all for what we do at
Manchester Central is at fire stations
across the country they say they've seen
a decade of falling real terms wages at
our last end now really we cannot see
firefighters and food banks which we are
doing I have friends who are visiting
five food banks who friends who are
struggling to to pay bills this isn't
jumping on the bandwagon this is
ultimately it's here and now sbu members
have voted by 88 for a strike the Union
Street deemed a result that could mean
its first Nationwide strike for 20 years
and in the week when we will see
thousands of teachers in England and
Wales join their Scottish counterparts
on the picket line the winter of
industrial discontentious grows
I think what's clear is that strikes are
not a last resort we have been
continuing conversations we have been
trying to see where we can find areas of
compromise but clearly it is not uh in
our we can't do something that is going
to really get in the way of our
objective which is to have a flesh
inflation
but unions rallied their supporters in
London knowing exclusive polling
commissioned by Sky News shows public
support for them growing
it will be weeks before firefighters
actually strike but with more action by
nurses and ambulance workers next week
we are increasingly facing the question
of what happens when those front line
Emergency Services just aren't there
Greg Milam Sky News Manchester